as today's episode opens we turn our
attention to Europe in a chapter that I
have needlessly confused everyone about
by asking you to read two chapters one
of which is not in your book which I
thought even for me that is just sort of
more negligence than I'm accustomed to
I'll tell you what the story is the
atotal the entire book the earthiness
people in the fourth brief Edition has
30 chapters so it divides in the middle
with 15 chapters in each half of the
book but the the splits that they've
published into a volume one in a volume
two divides 1416 rather than 15 15 so
over the weekend as I was looking up the
comprehensive version that I have at
home I saw oh I've come up a chapter
short and I intemperate Lee sent out a
request that you read an additional
chapter and then checked in my office
and discovered that Oh in the one volume
the volume one version of they're only
14 chapters so so the exams going to be
on that unread chapter clearly but there
was a good reason to to link the two
because it gets into a an issue that has
been central to the enterprise of world
history in at least the American version
of it pretty much from the beginning and
that is the question of what do you do
about Europe the 800-pound continent in
the room and the slogan to provincial
eyes Europe has been there to try and
treat Europe as if it were like any
other part of the world yet recognizing
that surely that will be very difficult
to do because first of all you so much
seems to happen that center door began
in Europe Center daughter began in
Europe and because the weight of the of
the library of history books that have
been written in Western languages is
vastly preponderant in the in the
European area but in in this book the
earth and of peoples up to chapter you
know chapter 13 we have done I think a
fairly good job of keeping a some sort
of perspective on the importance of
different parts of the world we may have
picked some awkward comparisons or use
some some bridging rubrics like tropics
that don't necessarily you know persuade
you very much but Europe was kind of you
know kept in a cage we did not spend a
lot of time on on aspects of European
history that in a traditional Western
Civ book or in general in earlier phases
of teaching history in American and
universities would have given more
weight to it but now we come to to the
question of Europe and it's particularly
accentuated in this chapter because the
title of the chapter is Latin Europe
there was a substantial debate within
the the author team about whether we
should have a chapter entitled Latin
Europe as opposed to simply Europe with
some sort of you know feel-good term to
it like you know not quite modern Europe
or something like that and the author
insisted that there was so much that had
to be written about Latin Europe that
you could catch up on other parts of
Europe at a later at a later point so we
ended up with a chapter entitled Latin
Europe the the extension of that chapter
almost it just reads flows on is in the
chapter that you don't have in volume
one and that is called European
transformations where you just continue
the story of European history Western
European history although in the
European transformations you have a
little more about parts of Europe other
than England France Italy and Spain
which is really the core of Western
European or Latin Europe European
history as conceived in this in this
chapter if you go back and you look at
earlier comments about Europe in the
book or in any other book you find
questions about what is Europe now how
do you define Europe the classical
definition of course was one that
situated Greece in Europe and as soon as
you crossed the Hellespont or you know
into Asia Minor you were now in Asia
Minor you won't in Europe anymore and so
we stole this notion that that the city
of Istanbul was divided between two
continents there's a European
and they an Asian Istanbul you go there
people talk about the ADA inside of the
European side as if they were you know
two sides of pretty much the same very
narrow body of water more alike them
then different you know you sort of like
taking Minneapolis and st. Paul and
saying you have two continents separated
by the Mississippi River it it's not
very persuasive
and it's particularly not persuasive
because when we think of the Greeks and
the Greek like kuba Navy the world the
known world and the minds of the Greeks
we tend to think of it from the point of
view of Athens now all those smart
Athenians but in fact the books that we
go to to look at this Greek world were
more other than not written by Greeks
living in Ionia that is to say along the
the Aegean Shore the Eastern Shore of
the Aegean in what is now Turkey because
even though you have a technical
division between a European continent
which has Greece in it and an Asian
continent that does not have grease in
it nevertheless you have lots of Greeks
living in Asia very likely more Greeks
living in Asia than you have living in
South Eastern Europe and certainly when
you have when you look at the library of
famous Greek authors you find Greeks
from Ionia playing a terribly important
role and this of course goes all the way
up to the beginnings of Christianity
where so many of the letters of st. Paul
are written to congregations in Asia
even though they were Greek speaking
congregations receiving letters written
in Greek so
the purely technical definition of
Europe as distinguished from Asia
through the body of water that that we
now see separating parts of the city of
Istanbul never seemed like a very solid
thing to base something on what appears
to have happened by the time you get to
chapter 13 is that Europe has come to be
defined as being a place of where
Christians are and non Europe is a place
where where there are no Christians not
at all there are lots of Christians in
non Europe it's just that the rulers
aren't Christians so it isn't even a
matter of of a one religion on one side
and one religion on another you have a
fairly consistent Christianity
throughout the area that comes to be
defined as as Europe and these later
chapters but you have lots of Christians
living outside of Europe including in
all of the Muslim ruled countries around
the Mediterranean but this chapter
narrows it down further to the laughs in
Europe by narrowing it to Latin Europe
space is made available to talk about
things like the Renaissance and
Renaissance humanism changes in
techniques of painting and conflicts
such as the Hundred Years War between
England and France I would submit that
the Hundred Years War between England
and France could probably be completely
deleted from the book without
significantly damaging
the you know the notion of world history
why this particular conflict is is given
oh let's say as much space as the entire
history of Korea or something
it sort of beggars the imagination
except for the fact that there are
certain stories that people who are who
were brought up on Western in history
feel really should be there for example
Joan of Arc
you know surely we need to have the
story of Joan of Arc we actually don't
need to have the story of Joan of Arc we
don't have to know that longbows were
used in the Battle of Agincourt or that
cannon were used in the Battle of Crecy
these are technological changes in war
and warfare that alter the balance
between two countries on the
northwestern rim of the of Europe but in
the broader scope of world history
do they really amount to very much now
here is where you get the problem that
is faced by world history textbook
writers not just in our team but in in
general how much of the of the sort of
gold and treasury of stories of the
European past can you discard without
really irritating the users the first
time I was involved in world history a
world history text one that was never
published I had a colleague who's in
charge of the project who was a very
very
expert storyteller wonderful American
historian named Jack Garrity and I wrote
about the Battle of Marathon and I said
you know after the Battle of Marathon a
Greek named Philippa Dee's or fade
deputies ran from the battlefield of
marathon marathon to the city of Athens
and and doubts that the Athenians had
won a great victory gives the Persians
and then he expired because of the of
the arduous nasaw and Jack said
something effective you know our
students they their mothers run the
marathon and then go home and cook a
meal you know who's going to believe
that somebody is going to drop dead
after running 26 miles and you know do
we do we tell this old story so I
thought well I'd best I better look into
the story so I read Herodotus we read it
and found he doesn't tell the story of
the run from marathon it appears in a
much later work called Dale OPSEU odd
salut salut tandem meaning abou the book
of those people who collapse after
giving salutations because this is a
literary trope you know you know Hail
Caesar
oh that sort of thing and and it appears
it's a late story it doesn't show up in
Iran it says on the other hand there is
a guy with a similar name in Herodotus
who ran from Marathon to Sparta to beg
the Spartans to come to the aid of the
Athenians the Spartans said oh we're
praying now and we won't be done for a
few days so we can't help you so he ran
back from Sparta to Marathon and if he
was the same guy who then ran 26 miles
from Marathon to Athens then he had run
something like 350 miles in a week
and no lots of people will die after
that nevertheless it raised question in
my mind as to what stories warrant
retelling is there any any list years
ago there was a an effort to to push
something called cultural literacy there
was a book published on this topic that
had a list of those things that every
cultured person should know and this was
to be used as a basis for for high
school education so people when they
graduate high school should be able to
take a test on cultural literacy and see
whether they have learned what is in in
their culture I happen to be on the
review committee of the National
Endowment for the Humanities when the
project came up I spent about an hour
and a half trying to shoot the project
down I said you know this assumes that
everyone in the classroom shares the
same culture and this was back in the
days when Lynne Cheney was head of the
neh and and people said well don't they
share the same culture you know aren't
all Americans American and note they all
know who Joan of Arc is and so forth and
so on and and ultimately the project was
funded and ultimately it led absolutely
nowhere
although perhaps it did help some people
do New York Times crossword puzzles I'm
sure but but there is this lingering
notion that there are certain things
that everybody should know at the level
of of anecdotes of stories as opposed to
at the grandeur level of people's
nations empires major changes in the
economy and
technology and social structure in
political philosophy and so forth we
have left out most stories in this book
often with regret because we do not have
the space in a world history text to put
in all the stories it would be good to
tell but when you narrow a chapter down
to only dealing with Latin Europe for a
period of 300 years it becomes possible
for you to tell to tell the stories and
that's fine
you know this is a chapter that mentions
Peter arc and Dante and Boccaccio and if
you're a Columbia student you have some
notion of these people are because we
have a core curriculum that preserves
the notion that we should all have a
common culture but most people in this
country do not know who Peter Ark was or
boccaccio although they may know a
little more about Dante but these
stories are in area in this chapter now
so the question I had raises at what
cost and do you is it edifying from the
standpoint of world history to be
offered a group of names and anecdotes
that are particular to Western history
that arguably may not have much of a
world historical impact such as the use
of the longbow at the Battle of
Agincourt not much of a world historical
impact there for artists like Leonardo
da Vinci or Michelangelo or for a figure
like Dante the argument to be made by
many people in humanities that there are
certain
thinkers writers artists whose work is
is so transcendent in its self-evident
importance that it should be part of a
world culture and I want you to think a
little bit about what the notion of a
world culture would be the United
Nations Foster's the notion of a world
culture and UNESCO has a a whole group
of about 800 world cultural sites and
they're distributed very very broadly
throughout all of the continents with a
very contrast idea of that that world
these world cultural sites world
historical sites should be so should not
focus upon a single area but if you if
you were to look not at sites like the
pyramids or the Great Wall of China or
oh the the ink and cities and the Andes
if you weren't to look at sites which
have the unique capacity or the unique
quality of not being movable but if you
were to look at things that are that our
mobile such as images or texts that
would be the question of should there be
or could there be a a set of world
cultural images and texts and if so is
Michelangelo more deserving of mention
than
than some Chinese artist or Indian
artists or Muslim artists or some
nameless artists who produced you know a
masterpiece of bronze casting in West
Africa or you know ceramic art in
Central America what would constitute
world cultural excellence and would
these Western Tech's be in it
it's a exit vexing question here at
Columbia for years we have had debates
over over great texts and great cultural
monuments and we have had a curriculum
that focuses upon those and the Western
tradition and the debate has been over
how and to what degree and in what
manner could one globalize this notion
of great for great images and great
texts on a world cultural basis one of
the solutions to this problem that came
up in the 1950s was a notion that the
great thinkers of the world exist in a
kind of platonic invisible at life of
the absolutes in which they hold a
conversation so that you can imagine you
know Freud in conversation with Conte
and conversation with Muhammad and
conversation with you-know-who Manchu I
mean whatever it's the idea that there's
some sort of of great interaction you
say well you know we're talking today
about Adam Smith but how does that
compare with what Aristotle said and
there you are you're a freshman
and or a first-year and you think I
can't remember at this point anything
Aristotle said about anything and much
less anything that would relate to
animus fail and so we this idea of a
great conversation was developed it came
to a head in the sand topic on which was
a great effort to to identify all the
themes of culture no angels evil you
know dog food whatever and and shall
give text references to everyone who had
mentioned these things but it really
didn't work very well because inevitably
what happened was that the Western
authors were taken as the benchmark and
everyone else was compared to them and
say in what way is X Y or Z like Cott in
his thinking or unlike cotton is
thinking the only course that attempted
to to take works of different completely
different cultures read them in the
class and the in translation and try and
get in to serve the dialogue was one
thought for a number of years by the
former Provost of Columbia
Theodore de berry and it was on it was a
thematically organized course that had
separate sections on East Asia South
Asia Middle East and Europe or euro
America and there were efforts to you
know if for a number of years every
spring there was a seminar that faculty
would go to who were interested in in
transcultural or intercultural
conversation it was very difficult it
was very difficult to read a Sufi poem
from eastern India and
compare it with let us say a a mystic
work from from Latin Europe and I think
the whole enterprise of thinking in
terms of a world culture that at the
level of texts and images needs needs a
lot more work how to do it and how to
make it in any way work in an integrated
fashion I think is is unclear to me even
though I taught in that course with Ted
to Barry for five years I was never
convinced that you could do this sort of
trans cultural intellectual and artistic
conversation but in this chapter the
dimension of famous writers and famous
artists is secondary to to other sorts
of events in keeping with the theme of
the book on technology environment you
have discussions of urban life
discussions of technological change
discussions of changes in warfare and so
forth all legitimate topics but what you
don't have is a very clear justification
for talking about Latin Europe we argued
with the author I would say I and other
people the author team argued with the
author of this chapter on the
restriction to Latin Europe and he was
adamant and it was his chapter so we
know we did it his way but now that I
read the chapter with some attentiveness
I'm struck by the stuff that was left
out in particular the the failure to
mention
anything about the Ottoman Empire here
you have a state that is a European
state there can be no question of that
the black death of 1348 caused a number
of tumultuous changes one of the less
known ones is that a year or two later
turkish warriors from the small state
known as by the name of its founder o
spawn crossed the you know the water
boundary between Asia and Europe and
became the founders of a new state which
was primarily a European State in other
words Othman was we understand him to be
a ruler in the northwest corner of Asia
Minor of Anatolia instantly this name
derives from the Arabic name earth man
which is the name of the third caliph
and if you were an Italian and you
couldn't pronounce the th and and
certainly you could not pronounce the
iron with which would aim begins with
man becomes Optima and then you put on a
suffix Optima no and you have ottoman so
that ottoman comes from Aslan by way of
Arabic and it shows the degree to which
the whole knowledge of what was
happening in the in Southeast Europe was
filtered through an Italian sensibility
and that it was the Italian
merchants seafarers who become
preeminent in the Mediterranean from the
12th century onward that become the the
people who know the most of the of the
Italians the most knowledgeable the
Italians among the Italians were the
Venetians and somehow Venice is
virtually unmentioned in this chapter
Venice and Genoa but more Venice and
Genoa developed very extensive trading
relations with the Muslims in Egypt and
the Muslims in Asia Minor and then when
the Ottoman Empire is established in the
course of the later 1300s Venice is
their main rival and you have a war
between the Ottomans and the Venetians
that's at least as long as the war
between the French and the English known
as a Hundred Years War but you can't
talk about Venice without talking about
the Ottoman Empire so we get lots about
Florence because that's sufficiently far
west - you know Florence and Rome but
Venice which shares at least as much as
any other major Italian city in the
glories of the Renaissance barely gets
mentioned the Ottomans set up a state in
southeastern Europe they do not really
begin to to penetrate further into the
Islamic Middle Eastern areas until after
1400 well 1380
it's a little bit before 1400 but their
first effort to set up a major state is
in Southeast Europe against the Serbians
and the Greeks and other people living
there so one of the things about the
Ottoman state from the very beginning is
that most
it's most of the subjects of the Ottoman
Sultan are not Muslims they're mostly
Christians so if you were to have
written a chapter on Christian Europe
then you have to include the Ottomans
because Christian Europe includes all
those Christians that we're living under
Ottoman rule in the Balkans and in the
Greek Peninsula but the insistence of
this chapter is on Latin Europe even to
the extent of having a map that grossly
falsifies things by showing the growth
of Latin Europe and showing that Latin
Europe increases by almost a third with
the adoption of Christianity in
Lithuania how many people know anything
about Lithuanian Christianity it's not a
popular subject but if you look at the
Lithuanian state which was actually a
Lithuanian polish Commonwealth which did
cover a huge area of Eastern Europe one
of the things you find was that at least
half the population were not Latin
Christians because this is an area that
included the Ukraine and included
Belarus it included Moldova it included
substantial areas that were Orthodox
Christian but the map we have in the
earth and his people's you know Awards
all of this - - laughing - Latin
Christianity why didn't I notice that
you know four editions ago I feel so
stupid to have let that pass because it
it creates a
a notion of the all-powerful force of
Catholicism which is not is not really
warranted and of course it also means
that if you don't include Eastern Europe
you are missing the areas in which you
have the most the most intriguing and
virtual interrelationship among groups
in other words you look at the Ottoman
Empire of southeastern Europe and you
see Christians and Muslims living in a
state governed by an ottoman sultan who
is a Muslim after 1492 this becomes the
paramount location for Jews who are
expelled from Spain by all those lovely
Latin Christians to find refuge so the
Ottoman Empire becomes the the primary
locus of the of the Spanish Jewish
communities who had been accustomed in
Muslim Iberia to having civil and indeed
often creative interaction with Muslims
and Christians they come to the Ottoman
Empire where in fact that creative
interaction to some degree continues so
the Ottoman Empire is a mixed is mixed
ethnically it's mixed linguistically
it's mixed religiously
things that are really outside the the
worldview of the Latin Christians in
Western in Western Europe the when we
think of the ruling class of the Ottoman
Empire we think of them as speaking a
language known as Ottoman or in Turkish
you would say most man woo
but that language was a highly refined
language based on Turkish grammar with
huge ad mixtures of Arabic and Persian
that makes very difficult for people
today to learn but it was a hallmark of
the of the learner delete of the Ottoman
Empire that they actually knew as a
standard cultural background three
languages Persian Arabic and Turkish I
point out that those three languages all
belong to different language families
it's as if you know it's often pointed
out Europeans know many languages and
all the European languages are basically
all dialects of one another
you know you so you know gee I know
Swedish Dutch and German yep yeah hold I
mean that's uh you know does that
qualify as turning you into a polymath
is it the same thing as knowing Oh Dutch
Telugu and Tagalog well no I mean not
many people will know those three but
lots of Europeans will know more than
one but in the Ottoman Empire the upper
class normally knew three languages from
three different language families it was
an elite drawing from
all of the communities in the religious
communities of the the ethnic
communities in the Empire and it
produced a a remarkably well-organized
and successful state under the Ottoman
Sultan in the textbook that I am
co-author of there is a single paragraph
devoted to the Ottomans prior to this
chapter and no discussion of the
Ottomans in this chapter and by the end
of the chapter you have gotten up to two
1500 and the business empires
disappeared because the Ottomans
conquered it Southeast Europe has been
swallowed up by the Ottoman Empire the
Ottoman Empire is the greatest enemy in
imaginable for most Christian Europeans
by the Year 1500 and yet it isn't
mentioned this is a this is a fault it
is not mentioned in the next chapter
because the next chapter is on which
we'll have next week is on the maritime
expansion of Europe primarily although
we do you know sort of wave our hats of
the Polynesians and a few others who
sail around and in the chapter after
that the mysterious chapter that isn't
in the book that's called European
transformations and there there is a
reference to the Ottoman Wars but
there's no description of the Ottoman
Wars or of the state against which the
ottoman wars were fought so you've
already gone through the ottoman wars up
to 1750 before the Ottoman Empire is
discussed in the book this is bad
thinking what were these authors
thinking about
if only I know it's it's it's very it's
very puzzling but many of the things
that you could say about the Ottoman
Empire were distinctive in a somewhat
different fashion about the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth which is coming
around at the same time a little bit
later we mentioned Lithuania in
opposition to the bond goals in an
earlier chapter that was where we have a
paragraph on the Ottomans but we don't
say what is distinctive about Lithuania
the implication is that Lithuania is a
national state that galvanizes its
national identity in opposition to to
the mongrel threat but there's nothing
there to intimated that the poles and
the Lithuanians who speak distinctly
different languages would come together
in a single state nor that that state
would not have a hereditary king but
rather would elect its king nor that the
election of the king would require
unanimous votes on the part of the
entire nobility which constituted 10% of
the population and the nobility drawn
from every ethnic and religious group in
the country when they would get together
for a political convention to choose a
new king it might last for six or nine
months and encompassed some local civil
wars in order to persuade people to vote
on the right way eventually a king would
come along and the King normally could
not pass his his crown on to a successor
poland-lithuania were religiously
strikingly neutral it was almost you
don't feed a perfect example of
separation of church and state so you
not only had every form of Christian in
it about of the nobility about 40
percent or a Greek Orthodox about 40
percent were laughing and then there was
another 20 percent who were other things
you had Muslims who were completely
integrated in the state to this day
there is a small community of people in
Lithuania known as of Lithuanian Tatars
who are the descendants of Muslims who
lived in that Lithuanian state and
played a a respected role in the polity
when the Protestant Reformation comes
along which technically is outside the
purview of this chapter
every powered Protestant denomination
seems to be tolerated and represented in
Lithuania Poland and there are no and in
the Wars of Religion between Catholics
and Protestants there are no there is no
participation by Lithuania they remain
aloof to all of the Wars of Religion
between Catholics and Protestants they
say religion is not is not what we fight
over here in Lithuania and eventually
they produce a constitution which is the
the world's second constitution after
the US Constitution 1792 is Lithuanian
Constitution it manages to offend the
the elites so profoundly that only lasts
for four years and then the entire
country is ripped apart and
distributivity and passes into existence
for hundred years but that's way in the
future my point is that when you read
about laughing Europe
you find a certain not only a collection
of well-known names and stories but a
certain narrowness that is taken as
represented as the primary
characteristic of the of these Europeans
since the expansion of Europe in
maritime exploration comes a different
chapter you don't see a balance between
the interior developments and the
foreign overseas adventures which would
be desirable you have a section in a
chapter that talks about the formation
of centralized kingdoms well of course
there is no Kingdom more centralized in
the Ottomans if this had been conceived
of as a chapter on geographical Europe
between 1200 and 1500 so that the
Ottomans were included and so that the
Iberian Peninsula became not simply an
area of Christian reconquest but it
included very substantial and important
cultural developments that occurred in
the Iberian Peninsula before the before
the Christian reconquest then you would
have a very different story indeed and
you would have a wonderful contrast in
other words we were willing to contrast
Rome and Han China but to contrast say
the Ottoman Empire with the Holy Roman
Empire or France or Britain or all three
in a sack in some way that would be a
very very different and very interesting
chapter
and we didn't do that what might happen
if you did it
the Europeans down to pretty much
through the 18th century considered the
Ottoman Empire a serious realm
comparable to the European realms in
other words the notion that the word
Europe should exclude the east and the
southeast was not the what was not
understood by European observers prior
to the 19th century indeed you can take
a humanists like Erasmus who looked on
Poland Lithuania as the ideal state of
which we don't really read about very
often but in looking at the Ottomans
what the Europeans saw was a superiority
of organization that they found
intriguing and challenging and dangerous
so that the fear of the Ottomans was not
simply a fear of their military
successes which were many but also a
fear of the the effectiveness of their
institutions this has become a great
debating point among among ottoman
historians that is to say the Ottoman
Empire expands and expands and then
stops expanding and there the question
has been raised did it stop expanding
because it had reached a natural limit
that is say the city of Vienna is the
most obvious point in Europe because in
1529 the first of two Ottomans sieges of
Vienna took place and the ottomans
failed to take the city so they never
got past Vienna so one school of thought
would say that that
Vienna was too far away from Istanbul
and if you started your campaigning
season by marching your army from his
stumble to the frontier to fight
Christians by the time you got to the
frontier you would be so far into the
summer and into the fall that that you
can only fight for a few days before you
had to turn around and go back home
in order to avoid the bad weather of
winter and this does play upon the fact
that they were claimed there were
weather factors affecting the first
siege of Vienna particularly in
preventing the Ottomans from bringing
their artillery up by by River transport
nevertheless there was nothing to have
prevented the Ottomans from stationing
an army near Vienna and simply starting
from the army camp instead of him
Istanbul but I think when historians in
recent times have tried to say that the
Ottoman Empire had a natural limit and
that once they reached that limit they
could not grow any more there's an
implicit comparison being made with
European states that created maritime
empires seemingly that had no limit in
other words for the French and the
British or the Spaniards or the
Portuguese the Dutch to to expand their
their reach through Imperial enterprise
you don't get much discussion of the
idea that well maybe there is a certain
maximum number of colonies that you can
have maybe beyond a certain point the
Empire couldn't grow any more rather you
have the idea that that a properly rung
Empire can grow and grow and grow so the
Ottomans seem to be Muslims who are
limited in their capacities to expand
whereas Europeans are not limited but
that's a historical interpretation there
are other interpretations as to why the
ottomans did not expand beyond
where they got to be on Vienna and those
interpretations often have to do with
just the complexity of reading large
states and the question of what is the
purpose of of expansion whether there
are other other ways to deploy state
resources than military expansion and
we'll see this next week and talking
about the Chinese expeditions to Africa
by sea you know huge expeditions that
with that sailed across the Indian Ocean
and then stopped was there a reason for
their stopping well it might have to do
with how much best when it was taking to
to launch those expeditions but be that
as may the ottoman empire fascinated the
europeans and what fascinated them as
much as anything was a specific cultural
institution that the ottomans had that
was known as
as the dev man the dev shooter
mat was a procedure for selecting boy
children to be trained to serve the
state they could serve the state as
soldiers and if they served the state of
soldiers they became members of the
Janissary Corps but they could also
serve the state as as commanders and as
administrators the general term for a
person who was taken in the dev geomat
was Kapahulu a cop the meaning the gate
and cold being a Turkish word for slave
it is the same as the word coolie that
the British picked up in India in the
you know from the terminology of the
Mughal Empire for for you know laborers
and in Mughal India so the slave of the
gate was a person who was selected by
the by the ruling establishment trained
either for military service or for the
most talented people for higher levels
of administration and to a substantial
degrees or not completely by any means
they provided the elite the rulers of
the Ottoman Empire not the Sultan's
but even up to the level of the Grand
Vizier that person could be someone who
started life as a
born into a Christian family in Serbia
or Albania or Bosnia and was taken at
the age of seven into into government
service trained rose through the ranks
became an administrator rose to the
administration it eventually becomes the
chief minister of the empire now there
are certain interesting things about
this this institution one of them of
course is that this is not a Muslim
institution the in order to be put in
the category of being a Kol of being a
slave you could not be a Muslim at least
theoretically Muslims cannot enslave
other Muslims therefore you had to come
from a from a religious background that
was non-muslim so most of the of the
people who were in the category of
Kapahulu were from Christian families
which means that the the ruling elite of
the Ottoman Empire pretty much from the
very beginning even before the dev chair
mail system when you have certain
eminent Christian families who worked
with the Ottomans in their conquest and
administration pretty much for very
beginning the Ottoman Empire is is ruled
by people from from Muslim and Christian
backgrounds and from different ethnic
backgrounds the
the Janissaries were placed in a
separate military contingent that
commanded the admiration of military men
throughout Europe because they were so
effective they were the first regular
military formation to use hand-carried
gunpowder weapons this required that
they be infantry because the weapons of
that time were so heavy that you could
not really fire them from horseback so
the cavalry portion of the Ottoman
Empire came from Turkish tribal or quasi
tribal families in Anatolia and Asia
Minor whereas the infantry largely came
from from soldiers of Christian origin
who were born in Southeast Europe the
the effectiveness of their weapons was
perhaps less important than the
effectiveness of their organization and
the the strictness of their discipline
they lived in barracks they were not
permitted to marry they were not
permitted to engage in business they
could not pass their position in the
military on to their offspring they were
dedicated protectors of the Ottoman
state you think where where did I read
about the idea that there might be
certain selected people who were
dedicated protectors of the state ah it
was in Plato's Republic where he talks
about the the watchdog's the the class
of people the Guardians who who will who
will be the ones that protect the state
and they will be selected because for
their natural qualities you know you
will you
know who is supposed to be a guardian
because they will have certain qualities
when the Ottomans sent out recruiting
not recruiting but selection committees
to go to these villages they would bring
together all the boys and they would say
well you know yeah you're too short
you're too skinny you're too fat you
look stupid but you know these guys over
here you know we'll take them so it
really was a selection and it was based
on the idea that there were natural
qualities that would be apparent in the
in these boys then they were brought up
and they were kept innocent of money
innocent of family innocent of
engagement of society they are simply
there to be the guardians of the state
it is almost a pure a pure play out of
Plato's Republic no one to my knowledge
has ever proposed this in the serious
written work no one has ever said I
think the Ottoman somebody in the
Ottoman elite must have read Plato's
Republic and thought about how do we
implement this ideal state you think
well the Ottomans are Muslims they speak
Turkish no no but we've already
established that among the elite of the
Ottoman Empire for the very beginning
that there were Greek not only people
who who read and spoke Greek but they
were Greek and they were not Muslims in
other words this wasn't a religious
thing this is it's entirely possible
that Plato's Republic was used as a
model we know from a reference in even
rushed in Spain at the time of the rise
of the Ottoman Empire that he had seen a
translation of Plato's Republic into
Arabic
we don't have any trace of that
translation but we do know that flavors
republic was a known work so the the
question of whether the ottomans were in
some either at second or maybe first or
second or third-hand living out a vision
of a state concocted by europeans rather
than a vision of the state concocted by
by the prophet muhammad would be
something that you could bring out if
you wrote a chapter on Europe rather
than a chapter that rather than taking
it as an assumption that everything
Muslim is to be separated from
everything Christian there is a term
that's used more generally
to talk about the Ottoman Empire not so
much used now as in previous scholarship
that's called bazhanov liaisons which
means Byzantium after Byzantium and the
idea was that the Ottoman Empire which
brings the Byzantine Empire to an end in
1453 but which has been ruling over most
Byzantine territory for 75 years before
that time the idea that the Byzantine
Empire lives on in the ottoman empire
because of the wholesale adoption of of
greek byzantine practices customs food
recipes costume everything else that
used to be a more popular idea than it
is now and a lot of this gets wrapped up
in the in the nationalistic biases of
turkish historiography where it would
not be particularly sound for a turkish
historian to say whatever we are we owe
to the greeks this would not be a good
thing to do and i don't mean by any
means to to belittle the sensibilities
here i was teaching a class years ago in
contemporary civilization and when we
read Plato's Republic I commented on how
the Ottoman Empire seemed to have
brought certain aspects of Plato's
Republic into being and a Greek student
in the class made me fear for my life he
said that the the Turks are you know
murdering oppressors and nothing that is
honoured by the by the name Greek could
ever be
conceived of by Maya Turk I don't think
one can casually dismiss this sort of
thing because what we have today
throughout Eastern Europe is a one after
another a panoply of nationalist
theorizing that demonizes the Ottomans
or demonizes the Turk the Ottomans more
on the not simply referred to as the
Turk regardless of whether the people
who are actually doing the fighting on
the Ottoman side were Serbs or Albanians
or blocks or Greeks or whatever the the
poisonous character of this nationalist
theorizing I don't think can be can be
readily dismissed it is it is simply too
deep
the truth of the matter is the truth of
the matter although I know that truth
hopefully the siren will cover that up
Leah they're about 14 European countries
that have been ruled by Muslim regimes
in toto or in part for over a hundred
years in their history in other words
Islamic rule has been extremely common
in the history of Europe but in the
history of Europe that we tell in this
chapter the Muslims do not appear except
as vanquished enemies of the bold
Christian warriors in Spain and Portugal
and and this I think is where our
textbook is part of the problem rather
than part of the solution the only
country that has really come to grips
with its Muslim past in Europe is a
Spain and that was a political as well
as a or perhaps even more than an
intellectual Enterprise this is a change
of view that is associated with the end
of the Franco regime and the positioning
of Spain by more recent governments to
be the interlocutor between the Muslim
world and end Europe it wasn't natural
necessarily for the Spaniards to say oh
we've really gotten along so well we
Christians and Jews well actually no
Jews left but we Christians and Muslim
well they're no Muslims left but you
know during those years when we let the
Jews in the Muslims be in Spain
we really got along really well with
them until we either killed him or drove
them out that there's something
someone's furious to this but you have
you have created the notion that there
was a unique moment in history when
Christians Jews and Muslims got along
and this was in Spain before but even
during these a period of the Christian
reconquest of the term used as a convent
yeah
living together some people would like
to expand the notion of Kabir Anthea and
talk about how do we live together today
and it's become a kind of a political
political term but historically you
probably had just as much living
together of Christians Jews and Muslims
in the Ottoman Empire as you had in
Spain it's just that you can't readily
talk about it because of the political
sensitivities when you have people from
half a dozen European countries who have
been brought up to believe that every
single moment of Ottoman rule was a
moment of Terror oppression torture and
villainy that that destroyed the the
fortunes of the nation and stole the
young men who would have made the nation
great if they had not been drafted into
the Ottoman army so to my mind what I
would like to see world history books do
and I would like to see our book do in
its next edition is to look at Europe in
this period as a
as a whole to include Eastern Europe to
include South Eastern Europe to include
the Ottoman Empire and to to do a kind
of comparison between what you had in
Latin Europe and what you had in other
parts of Europe and see to what degree
there is something European here as
opposed to to accepting a priori the
notion that the boundary between
Christian and Muslim is a fixed and an
immutable boundary so when you have a
section as you have in this chapter that
talks about the the vicious atrocities
against Jews perpetrated by by
Christians at the time of the Black
Death it might be valuable to say well
in other parts of Europe Jews were
well-received after 1492 and land
productive and prosperous lives under
under Muslim rule so I guess what I'm
doing here is making a plea to the
unknown authors of this book to to
revisit their table of contents one
possibility would be to go back and
revisit that chapter on the Mongols and
say was it right to view the Mongols as
the center against which everybody else
to which everybody else reacted was it
right to say that the Mongol threat was
the formation of Japan or the Mongol
overlordship was the formation of Russia
or the Mongol peril was the the
rationale for the Mamluk state in Egypt
was it right to portray a
a great conquering force of unquestioned
power and competence as being the
formative influence in which case the
ottomans turn into like lithuanian they
turn into just a paragraph in the
context of the mongol impact or would
have been better to have to have
reserved some of this impact for
discussion in a different context and i
would suggest in this context here so
how to repair the decision to exclude
the mongols from this chapter may not be
a matter of simply rewriting this
chapter which I'd be perfectly happy to
do but a matter of Rican sieving a
sequence of chapters and in the process
to redress or to address explicitly
something that was only implicit which
is what is Europe what is Europe it is
not at all clear that understandings of
Europe I mean people continually for the
last hundred years have said what is the
Middle East where is the Middle East
what is it in the middle of what is it
east of etc etc etc as if that's a
problematic area and that Europe is just
a given well no all of these areas are
our constructions intellectual
constructions and they all need they all
deserve to be interrogated and I think
Europe is the one where we have as of
the fifth edition not done a sufficient
job of of interrogating the units that
we are using for laying out this history
of the world and on Thursday I will talk
about something else
you